e allora sì facendo sì ci ho messo una
porzione siamo più forti ora aiuto cosa
succede a fuoco no è la porzione della
forza ma scusa minore nella stiamo
sfruttando le rinunce nessuno che mi
ordina viene che tipi ti picchio con voi
non funziona allora ragazzi erano
rimasti che dovevano andare nella
caverna del drago mini nella dragons lei
ci sono delle cose c'è anzi una cosa che
prima di andare nella dragonslayer
dobbiamo controllare che me l'avete
detto voi grazie a dio che ci siamo
dimenticati cosa stai facendo non c'è
più spazio dove buttare altri attraverso
devo portare va bene o prima scelta per
la gara con i complimenti ho capito
spostiamo a leh dove lascia lì non
importa me l'avete detto voi grazie a
dio me lo avete ricordato che quando
eravamo all'inizio del gioco c'era il
portale dell'ente cosa che noi non
abbiamo mai esplorato quindi dobbiamo
riaprire la prima caverna e andare nel
portale del network e non avevo ancora
perché dell'inferno non ci siamo ancora
andati e c'era un portale che non
abbiamo mai altre passato quindi
muoviamoci smettere farc agate vieni non
ci siamo persi proprio sta roba è
l'ultima zona prima di arrivare nella
dragon slayer e il network e ancora non
abbiamo visto se magari ti muovere
capiamo l'aquila la sua qui sono qui ok
vai necker questo è il rituale per
battere il drago del land dopo va bene
ecco lo uccide il pulcino e batteremo il
drago ma io proprio con questo elemento
dovevo fare una serie di minecraft
scegliere tu potevo scegliere surreal
power pietro ma un deficiente ho scelto
ma perché il problema va bene per
ragazzi
e questo nel net si è leader non sui
termini trasmetti allora entriamo
non so se c'è qualcosa dall'altra parte
guardino di ferro non ho idea di che
cosa ci sia dall'altra parte forse porca
vacca che ha tratta cosa no non è vero
non è successo
no non è vero glory no non è vero non è
successa questa cosa hai un accendino
no allora dimmi ora c'è un problema nel
senso il portale non si può accendere in
nessun volo grazie a due moglie ok
il primo è se non l'acciarino era cerino
un accendino
non ho l'accendino maledizione che
vadano all'inferno con l'accendino io ho
cultura perché sai che prima socio delle
casse ho fatto le casse in più
praticamente io ho detto ma portiamoci
in legno che non si sa mai
quindi all evento quindi se noi
riusciamo a portare qua la lav a dar
fuoco al legno e far prendere fuoco alle
nella parte interna del legno quindi sul
portale il portare seri a cena non siamo
a dar da dario a me geiler cos'è sta
roba modulo è l'unico modo questo vuoi
dare fuoco al collo semplicemente
portando la lava qualche esatto quindi
la troviamo nella lava maledizione nel
dedalo è più in là vacua è laggiù ecco
la vedova qua scusi scusi signora la va
a provenire un attimo come voi che la
forti ma edizione in un tunnel 1x2 sono
prontissimo lo vedo cosa facciamo così
prima di tornare indietro andiamo a fare
un fiorino ok va bene poi vediamo di
portare la lava doveva portare 6 valido
vediamo a lingua
ok
bello beh per l'idea andiamo nel letter
dicevano ti divertirai diceva ma
l'eccezione
dobbiamo andare di saw e allora tu per
me poi rimanere anche sotto credo di
aver trovato la lava amico tanta
abbastanza uno spettro sudato torce qua
di un attimo non c'è quindi qua torce
d'ora in fondo ma che tu alla serie
tutti i butti veramente stanno spingendo
zeno riesco a vabbè jolo ma porc di una
marca e schifosa maledetta ma è
possibile ma veramente
ma no dai vai a cagare aveva almeno l in
una nota positiva c'è sappiamo da che
punto far cadere la lava o questo
cercando di capire come posso portarla
come dei maya paglia pietraia sofia
sofia pietro pietro sofia sta morendo
no non è la porzione della vita
istantanea se non sei morto
alla sua morte da mera da melanoma che
da me la volevo perla l'ho lanciata
addosso bellissima foto lara gut a
pietro pietro l'aiuto pietro pietro sei
un bombolo non sei morto vero no però
quasi o la mozione lo possono lanciare
la cosa avrà da sopra lancia la firma da
sopra ma se il deficiente all'elezione
porca di una barca maledetta c'è già il
portale tra l'altro con l'accendino non
serviva a niente ma scusami da questa
parte c'è il portale l'altra noi esatto
forse riattivato pure lì qua no no no se
li attiva e se lo vedo io sono mica
stupido sa ma un altro può trovare ha
fatto fini per questo cose c'è ancora
c'è ancora questo wat 2 ma come si sa
perché vabbè
a parte sto casino vogliamo proprio ho
capito sto guardando in giro stai zitto
non aveva ostacolo in questo posto
abbiamo sopravvissuti a delle cose
incredibili san martino dei deficienti
feb è una scusa o no space esperti c'è o
non c'è nessuno lo spacchino conosco
cassero
ma quanto ti cali addosso
tu sei pazzo a fare quello che abbiamo
fatto e volevo che salta synth e
scavalca nel suo cinema va bene direi
che possiamo così qua siamo di nuovo
nello spazio aperto va bene direi che a
questo punto visto che il portale c'è
grazie a dio meno questo solo morto ma
qualcosa è servito torniamo che andiamo
a scolare land ed è la cosa che mi preme
di più fare perché è l'ultimo obiettivo
che ci rimane dove è riuscita e dove
dove sventola the floor e che non vedono
anche pitte dove stare qua ecco qua ha
voglia di farti tutto indietro e c
[Musica]
no no basta ecco la mia passione va bene
o del gruppo di questi è morto ora
cavalca no perché mi 4 basta farsi il
deficiente apre che mi seguono tutti
adeguati un cuore continua non potesse
venir qua aiuto aiuto aiuto della
precedente aiuto per due mobili ci
aspetta aspetta cavato cosa c'é qua
sotto che figo guarda che ti arriva
d'ore maledetto bimbo stupido ucciso il
padre ma stai zitto google è per lui ha
trovato un golden nugget aia porca vacca
bambini mi hanno fatto una golden sword
più 6,5 di daya ma basta ama troppo
nuova forte questi quando ti arrivano
attacco insultante sai dire che possiamo
tornare magari sonora che mi fanno male
gesù meno male che sono riusciti a
uscire in qualche modo vai
ok a questo bene e potevamo anche non
guardarlo net però beh questa servono o
e la spagna dopo cos'era ciocca che
conoscono aina freccia negi no grazie
allora direi che così come si è ammessi
po della roba in più che ho per andare a
mangiare andiamo alle salento mentre si
ok dovremmo avere tutto in teoria o
blocchi o cibo
occhi di ender che servono per aprire il
portale e direi che mi sono dirigerci
verso l'ultimo dungeon di questo hai
messo la difficoltà al massimo si crea
il massimo diamo man dragonslayer by
prima tu vai primo dei signori vado
prima io ammazzo strada che bello è
rientrata e figgis e l'entrata delle
cose bellissime allora bisogna spaccare
aspetta qualche un pacco l'orchetto
spacca è quanto quanto dura spaccata
credo che aleggia per entrare ci abbiamo
messo un'ora e mezza a scusarmi striscia
compito si calmò che fastidio facente
dall'ava occhi niente presse i 9 12 23
anni ma io 12 il culo neo precisi nel
futuro le brava e vocazione mentre io
piazzo gli occhi il gioco dice che per
aprire il portale un tuo compagno deve
cantare gang am style by mitzi iniziano
veloce veloce dhurandhar di yoga stai tu
che vai ci siamo bye bye
www ragazzi io credo che tutti ma come
vi ho fatto apprendimento di cd preciso
perché abbiamo preso abbiamo fatto fuori
tutti gli altri no quindi nelle ceste
c'erano il numero preciso di età hai una
freccia hai sempre ci andrò più una non
è portare ma persa grazie
puoi essere più stupido ferme puoi
essere una persona perché aia non l'ho
presa neanche i video a 319 ma io c'ho
all'infinito
anch'io infinite andreotti occhio andrea
uscire veloce come io non l'ho mai fatta
questa cosa aiutami e non so dove si
gioca è minecraft novaggio calamai per
fare di sanzioni per l'appena scala
interessati teoricamente ci fa sfumare
certo sotto terra
ecco infatti luce becchiamo la luce
questa
31 boss finale allora guarda per terra
eccolo quella portata corre per terra se
tu porti negli occhi negli anni and her
man lord staccano ha già questa allora
va affatto così prima di distruggere il
drago ayane no
esatto di rompere quello pd ok torrette
danno vita al drago e la madonna che tu
stai facendo non ha capito la faccio io
mentre tutti fi picchiare a sangue ma
tutti dobbiamo far fuori vedere ma che
palle e lo so è una roba un po lunghi
proviamo a farlo per fermare che sono un
cecchino
e vabbè ma quanti sono alcuni sono
altissimi recapito
ok e nel mentre drago cimena esatto pure
ma se io lo butto giù adesso esplode per
cado giù di merda e non posso non posso
distruggerla loris con gli altri ok poi
sei tu ok sono sopra un coso che non
posso distruggerlo l'esplosione mi fa
cadere l'aiuto non so ma ti mancano e
non ne vedo tanti può essere con unit e
mi rifiuto di credere queste cose le
cose te le cose in comune è così ci
mettiamo un ora dopo un anno così
cretino
ok la mia roba borja valero
ok grazie ad esso se ti infili magari in
le mani nel culo facciamo anche provare
a fare questa roba
poi non riesco a prendere quelli bassi
di cose più riuscito a prendere un chilo
primo fuoco poi non pensavo neanche
dipendere dalla sorella
ok ho visto forse l'ultimo a dove di là
sopra è quello
è un ora che sto imparando ok distrutto
si danno nell'ultimo occhio e faccio le
ultime questo boom mandato ha colpito
vediamo se altri raggi drago ha già
perso vita al drago my lai colpisci
drago
mi chiamo attore viene tolto credo ahi
ahi a chiamare aiuto che mira a un
macello è difficilissimo la cosa sembra
di giocare contro casa e lo hobbit bene
tu brutto e inutile essere umano crasha
proprio quando serve porca vacca e
crociato pietro quando cenarono per le
balle la connessione di funziona
benissimo quando c'è da fare le cose
tipo questa crush un genio in poche
parole questo è l'utilità di pietro gli
amici che vede che si vedono nel momento
del bisogno sempre così e non è un caso
succede spessissimo altra causa
poi tranquillo tanto senso non più
diretto da solo che con te cretino dai è
direction così diventa milena eccomi
eccomi pensa non avessimo l'arco con
infiniti e bulgari arrivano arrivano a
masate pietro vi prego ammazzate
liberale intermezzo giorni spero che ti
ammazzo
bravo pietro mai mancato
che figata guarda ora sembra di aver
battuto un super sayan è uscito un pene
dietro la roma l'esperienza non toccare
quello di non toccarlo
io quanto esperienza prendi prendi
prende se non toccare ancora in mezzo
non toccarlo 60 questo ancora da quattro
allora non va toccato perché è l'unico
modo per prendere per l'uovo è con un
pistone con un pistoris e 299 no e non
toccarlo e va bene come colpi stoner un
pistone e poi trovarlo esatto
va bene cosa dobbiamo fare è del sud
2003 nel portale riusciamo
dio mio cerchio
così è successo ci sono i titoli di coda
di mantra esatto guarda anche non sapevo
potessero esserci ritiri di cose in mine
che ti voglio chiedere una cosa
bwin mentre andiamo a prendere luogo ma
che io sappia mai minecraft non hanno
aggiunto un altro boss dopo darlo non è
proprio dopo è insieme diciamo son due
boss altrettanto difficile che a un boss
altrettanto difficile e come si fa il
leader
vogliamo allora ci servirebbero tre
teste del reader x evocato anche chi è
un delle teste perché sono in giro
questi cavalieri neri nel never che
quando lucidi hanno la possibilità di
tre parti la testa del with her ok
nell'età di molte esatto domani riunione
uccidere questi cavalieri prendere tre
teste e possiamo quel punto e vocale
with her però firettore ammazzato il 93
è bello difficile molto difficile dove
lo è ma chi nella tua terra vuoi
provocarlo quindi quando sull'isola e
dove vuoi possiamo carlos in lettere la
battaglia finale di naufraghi sarei
giocare sto tizio qua per poterlo
battere sull'isola quindi non residenti
di sporgere tutto quello che abbiamo
listru perdiamo tutto perdiamo te lo
dico va bene ci state boss finali devono
essere poi che non avere va bene dovrà
avere quella strizza quindi agli ospiti
di corsa a prendere sta roba dell'uomo
che poi voglio assolutamente prendere
quello deve assolutamente fare questo
boss
ok te ovviamente come di consueto per
l'ultimo d'angelo va allestito l'ultimo
cartello che metterò in questo momento
ok ci sei
diamo arriva un attimo famiglia fine ma
quest altro boss che possiamo battere
come è tosto secondo me ma io no io io
sai che non ce l'ho presente e non lo
andrò assolutamente a vedere su google o
piacciono neanche presente di espresso
solo me lo avevano raccontato che c'è un
altro boss ma non ho idea di come si sa
come si sblocchi di quanto sia difficile
non ho idea di niente dopo gli svelerà
air è molto più difficile tra del land
molto più difficile
devo mettere pistone po dietro l'altro
metto io perché voce farlo ma ammazzati
l'amico pistone che sembra una frase
brutti sia una vera beni bravo bravo
magari la faccio io spiega pagina più a
nastro ne va ok non ridere allora porca
vacca difficilmente un pistone
ma perché ma se io l'ho punto vado a
metterlo va
pensato come possiamo pensare di battere
l'ultimo boss se non riusciamo a
metodiche non avevo restate no la leva
il compito di papaleo
eccolo qua
questo è quello intravisto ale e il
trofeo del drago chicche che si è messo
lì a provare col qui pistola vedere se
si potrà trovare che malattia e vabbè
c'è veramente alcalà cup cosa guardato a
non abbonati toccano più si city attacca
la via via vere veloce sorice marcia ho
riferito il gioco sono forte
allora direi che per adesso con tutta
europa che abbiamo fatto le cagate
pietro che abbiamo fatto non so abbiamo
sconfitto l'ultimo boss di tutti quanti
d'angelo quindi ricapitolando abbiamo
fatto
non mi ricordo anche più i dungeon però
abbiamo 1234567 con il dragon slayer e
l'ottava sarebbe la caverna quella di
base che lo avevamo qualche abbiamo
fatto all'inizio quindi abbiamo fatto
praticamente tutti quantità di modalità
difficile quindi sono usciti a fare una
vacca abbastanza decente strano da quel
maledetto deficiente lì che fa solo
casino
ho tentato di tiro alto di nuovo ma non
che colpì bravo quindi ragazzi nel
prossimo episodio la cosa che cerchiamo
di fare è di battere il boss quello
finale noi giocheremo qua direttamente
sull'isola sopra il tetto e cercheremo
di farlo fuori
non è lady come si sa non me lo voglio
sperare non me ne frega niente per ora
video vi sia piaciuto che ha senso che
quando mi piace anche meno
tiziano soldavini scadere ci vediamo
novità
[Musica]